[Musique]
tu as pu filmer au moins
mais que tu me payes pas assez pour
faire ces conneries la chaîne est en
train d'exploser si de la thune qu'on
encaisse bébé mais tu sais on peut en
faire plus si on faisait sa une émission
et si on allait chercher de vrais
monstres 1 à l'attention de tous les
monstres dans la région de los angeles
recherche des sujets pour un
documentaire intitulé le monster
prochaine
écoutez je crois qu'on devrait pas
chercher ce genre de choses vraiment
c'est quoi ça on a reçu une nouvelle
réponse à la petite annonce et c'est une
vampire tout le monde aime les histoires
d'horreur
on préfère croire que les monstres
n'existent pas monster project scène une
prise une
mais s'il existait vraiment et vivait
parmi nous je comprends que vous vouliez
cacher votre identité pour votre
protection bats pour ma production
mais pour l'amour je le vois va-t'en
va-t'en lui
saison qu'on aura mené pour l'interview
ce type à des écrevisses revenus de
payer pour tes péchés